[Music]
i'm thrilled to welcome back noah
feldman you can find him on twitter at
noah r feldman
f-e-l-d-m-a-n you can find him online at
noah hyphenfeldman.com
our first interview can be found at team
dot blog slash noah
and
this is an experimental format we are
going to try to explore some
current events let's just say also tie
in historical context i very rarely do
anything other than evergreen content
questions and so on on this podcast but
i thought it'd be fun to
dip our toes in the water
and attempt to do something unique and
i'm thrilled that noah was willing to
play this game and be part of the
experiment so thank you for being here
noah
i was born to be a lab rat i'm very
excited
[Laughter]
and we have specked out a few different
subjects
a few different topics that
we'll attempt to navigate and i use the
royal we here because it's gonna be
mostly you i think i'm sure that won't
be true but i will
play the part of audience stand-in and
i'll ask questions
let's begin with
ukraine and you can kick this off in any
way that makes sense in the micro the
macro or otherwise how would you like to
begin
i think a good place to start is with
the question
that never really gets asked in all of
the coverage of this long war
and that is
why do people go to war in the first
place
and that might sound like a stupid
question because people like stuff and
other people have the stuff and if i
have an army and i can take your stuff
why not go to war and that does seem to
be sort of at some very basic level
what's going on here right i mean putin
just calculated that he had an army and
he wanted at least part of ukraine and
maybe more and he could do it
but the real question that's underlying
that is a question about whether people
who run countries are a little bit
rational you don't have to believe that
they're completely rational you just
have to think that when they decide to
go to war they know people are going to
die they know it's going to cost them
something they also know there's
something to be gained
and so the assumption that they're
rational is just an assumption that
they've thought about the pros and cons
of doing it and i think in the case of
someone like putin
who may have made a tremendous
miscalculation with this war
but has been pretty successful in a lot
of his other foreign policy undertakings
you can be sure he thought it over
and so the question that raises is
if
tim has a very very large army
and i have a very small army and tim
wants my country
and tim comes to my border he masses his
troops and says hey
i want let's say your two your two
favorite provinces
and i say no
and tim says well then i'm going to
invade you
and a lot of people are going to die
some on my side but a lot on your side
and at the end i'm going to have the
provinces
and i say huh holy crap i mean maybe tim
is correct and if tim is correct i
should just give up
because i'm going to lose the provinces
anyway
and
fewer people will be dead and i won't
have destroyed my army which i might
need another day and meanwhile you
should only make that threat if you're
very confident that you're gonna win
so logically speaking it's a puzzle
right why does anyone actually fight the
war
and i'm fascinated by that question and
i think ukraine
really really raises it
well
how would you
make an attempt to answer that question
do you think it was a miscalculation
i have heard stories and i'm sure i'm
going to get the historical details
completely wrong but
maybe it was belgium
with the
sort of procession of germans
pre or during world war ii
but the underdog standing up and having
only a snowball's chance in hell but
nonetheless having a snowball's chance
in hell
and
and defeating the odds defying the odds
why do you think
we have ended up where we are or do you
think there was a rational calculation
or perhaps even in what some people
would consider an irrational calculation
i was thinking about this yesterday for
instance i think a lot of lower income
folks get
made fun of by people who are
sanctimonious
in the higher echelons of society for
buying lottery tickets and they say
well that's just a tax on the poor right
it's stupid but then i was thinking is
it really stupid maybe it's buying hope
for a dollar a day in which case if
having a sliver of hope is only costing
you a dollar a day that's actually the
bargain of a lifetime
so
how would you begin to tease apart
how
what you just described has played out
in ukraine versus russia
first of all let me say i love that
example of the lottery tickets it's one
of my favorite examples of
how elitists
and you know i'm perfectly capable of
being elitist sometimes so this is not
an argument that all leaders are bad or
that everyone's an elitist but
why elitists get it wrong
because they think i wouldn't get any
joy or pleasure
out of spending a buck which i'm
probably going to lose so whoever does
it must be delusional using a rational
act of calculus and they fail to realize
there's what you might call
entertainment value but even
entertainment is understating it hope is
really a feeling that matters
now that doesn't mean you should spend
hundreds of dollars that you don't have
on lottery tickets but it is an argument
so there's a direct analogy to that in
the case of war
and
the example that comes to my mind
the snowball's chance in hell where they
don't succeed
is poland
when germany invaded in 1939 starting
the second world war
and famously the polish cavalry
which was still
riding horses
went out on moss basically
in the face of the german tanks and they
only lasted a few minutes they lasted
less than an hour and they kind of were
killed wholesale and it's easy to look
at that and say oh my god that's so
irrational
but what you're forgetting is that
people have honor
and dignity
and if you are a cavalry officer and
you've devoted your life to
a principle of honor
and pride
there may be no choice in that moment
literally no choice in that moment
but to go and be willing to sacrifice
your life because that's what your code
teaches you and your code is
the most important thing to you
in that moment
you could also think of this in the
context of you know 911
one of the fire chiefs
a guy called ray downey who had was the
chief who had started rescue one which
was the part of the new york fire
department that goes to save firemen who
are in trouble
and he went back into the buildings
when i think it was extremely must have
been extremely clear to him
that he wasn't going to come out of
those buildings
and
you know that's a product of spending
your life saving firemen and there were
firemen in harm's way
and he must have in my imagination at
least made the judgment in that moment
which i deem a heroic judgment
that he didn't want to walk away from
those buildings that day that would have
been a violation of everything he stood
for so for sure there is an element of
that and sometimes if you're standing up
and fighting for your country even
against the odds it should be explained
in that way that you know you're going
to lose
but your dignity and your pride
matter enough to sacrifice your life and
so that can be an explanation sometimes
for why a side that thinks it's going to
lose a war
even it's sure it's going to lose the
word it doesn't stand up
so you do need to take that into account
but that probably doesn't cover the
decision of all statesmen
you know and states women you know the
people at the top whose job it is to
take into account not just pride but the
interests of their whole
nation
and so there's a very interesting theory
about why people even in that situation
go to war which i've always been
fascinated by and i don't think i buy it
100 but i think it's really valuable to
think about it
and it was introduced by a guy called
james firon like fear with an on at the
end of it
in he's a political scientist
and his argument was the following
even if everyone's rational you can
still have people go to war
when
there's genuine uncertainty
about who's gonna win
because the two sides don't have the
same information
about who's gonna win they have
differential ideas so in his theory
take the putin example putin's thinking
i'm gonna win this war which is what
most external observers thought
including a lot of military observers
whom i respect a lot a lot of people
thought he would win the war putin would
win the world he'd win the war fast
much bigger army
lots of military experience
but
it was also possible
that even if not very probable that
ukraine would do a lot better in its own
self-defense
than
anyone thought it would including putin
and it may be that the ukrainian
leadership thought that
but as it turns out there's a big
advantage to defending as opposed to
invading that always gives you a big
advantage and then the ukrainian
soldiers had many of them been trained
by nato forces so they've had excellent
training
and it may just be that the ukrainian
leadership apart from their pride and
their dignity which i'm sure were also
factors just had a different opinion
about what would happen in the war and
according to furon if the two sides have
different opinions about what's going to
happen then you go to war
because you don't have perfect
information about the outcome so that's
a theory according to which you can be
rational and still fight the war and i
think that probably explains at least in
part what happened here putin was really
confident that he would win
and that the ukrainians would fold and
they said i'm not so sure i think we can
actually make a better stand against you
and in this instance
at least at first with respect to the
all-out attack on ukraine they were
right i mean that's the sort of most
astonishing fact about the war to date
namely that in the opening weeks
russia didn't just successfully take
down the capital of ukraine and conquer
the whole country and put in a puppet
government which they said they wanted
to do more or less at the beginning
and when that didn't go that well
you moved on to the next phase of the
war which is its own fascinating topic
in which they've decided to aim for
these two provinces
that have lots of russian speakers in
them and it may have been what they
wanted in the first place
and so the phase of the war that's been
continuing
is a phase of the war where they've got
much more limited objectives the
russians have much more limited
objectives
but they're still fighting
and the ukrainians are still fighting
back
so that just deepens the puzzle what are
they each fighting for now
so i'd love to jump in with a few
questions and
uh maybe bookmarks just for
discussion so the the first is
and you and i have spoken about this but
perhaps those
limited objectives
are not revisions but were the
objectives from the outset but they can
be viewed then as a concession or a
secondary now even though it's been part
of the plan all along
and
i'd love to explore two things with you
that i think could apply well one could
apply certainly to multiple conflicts
and that is what the what the stakes are
in this particular conflict in your mind
and then one that is perhaps
one topic that may be
unique or somewhat unique to this
conflict which is what has made this
different
and
there are a number of factors i'll just
throw out there as
plausible
elements factors right one would be
the ability
to cheaply and broadly broadcast from
the ukraine using social media and so on
borderless
and permissionless in some
cases transfer of cryptocurrency
from around the world to support ukraine
and then also the interplay
of private or semi-private
players
so for instance and i haven't tracked
this most recently so i don't know what
has been confirmed
or denied or both
but the
drone manufacturer dji disabling certain
capabilities of its firmware selectively
for the ukraine forces and then on the
opposite side starlink which has been a
godsend for ukrainian forces
so that the two buckets then are stakes
and then
separately what makes this
unique
or interesting at least in this time and
space
and i'd love you to tackle whichever you
think
you would like to first
those are fascinating questions and
they really
make us wonder
what's unique and special about this war
what makes it different
and of course from the ukrainian
perspective at least at the beginning
the war was existential they couldn't
stop and from a european perspective
what makes this war really special and
the reason that europe has organized
itself so much in support of ukraine
is that they recognize the rest of
europe recognizes that if putin can walk
into ukraine and take over large chunks
of it or the whole thing
that he's a serious threat to the other
countries in the region and that the
basic idea that europe is a safe and
secure place where you can go from place
to place without worrying about it where
war has been you know rendered obsolete
is just false
and so that helps explain why it's so
important to them
it also explains why it's important to
the us
and all that gives you some reason to
understand why it's constantly still in
the news even though i think a lot of
people
some days i admit to my shame myself
included just don't follow it anymore
you know i mean we sort of
you know the the the glib analogy would
be you know we're used to the the
playoffs happening and at the end of the
playoffs there's the finals doesn't
matter which sport you're following
and then you get a break
and this war you know they're still
you know it's like they're still having
the world series in october and then
november and then december it's just
going on
but the reason the world is continuing
to care about it and pay attention to it
is at least in part those kinds of
global consequences and the basic
question there is
can europe be a stable place or is
europe
going back to the olden days where a
government that had a serious army could
just take over countries that it didn't
like
so that's to me where i start
and then come the questions that you're
raising
how does technology differ here how does
crypto differ here
how does the war
social media side expressing itself and
how are those things distinct from the
past so let me say a couple of things
about that
there have been some really creative
efforts especially on the ukrainian side
to try to use
crypto web 3.0
in order to kind of link themselves to
the to the zeitgeist you know to the
moment and gain some
advantages from it so a really
interesting example of that is the the
ukraine dao
which
ukraine kind of came up with
that basically
was
attempting to
enable crypto to be transferred
into the country
and then
that would enable them to fight their
war better basically
by donors
you know it's basically a clever way to
get people to make direct donations to
ukraine without going through banks
and
measured statistically that's probably
not turning the tide in the war you know
as a percentage of all the aid that
ukraine is getting from countries and
governments especially military aid it's
probably still a drop in the bucket
but the fact that they could do it is
what's significant the fact that they
could say
we're going to try to draw on
contemporary technology opens the
thought that hey maybe this is a way
for aid to be sent from ordinary
citizens to a country more over time and
we've seen other kind of less exciting
hacks like that sort of at the beginning
of the war
lots of people who wanted to send money
to individuals in ukraine were using
airbnb yeah they were booking airbnbs in
ukraine that they had no intention of
going to and paying for them
and
since airbnb had a payment mechanism in
place that was a way to make donation
now it may not be the way to make the
most effective donation it's a subsidy
to the those ukrainians who already had
airbnb setups but it was a symbolic and
meaningful way of of getting involved
but probably not transformational on its
own
it does raise the possibility though of
how these kinds of tools are going to
operate in future wars
i will say one thing about it though
it's entirely possible that in the long
run crypto would be to the advantage of
an aggressor like russia
rather than being to the advantage
of a state like ukraine that's defending
itself and that has the world more or
less behind it because the main
sanctions that the world is
putting on russia now are economic
sanctions i mean that's the other
fascinating thing about this war it's
still really being fought sure arms are
being sent to ukraine but the west is
basically fighting this war economically
it's trying to [ __ ] russia
and those sanctions mean
for example making it hard for russian
banks to operate making it hard to
transfer money into russia through the
international banking system and those
are pretty effective tools and sanctions
in principle
if the russian economy could operate via
crypto
and crypto were not very heavily
regulated the way it is not yet
then russia would have the capacity to
evade
a lot of those international sanctions
using crypto and i think
from the standpoint of crypto advocates
one of the really important things to do
has been to make sure that the narrative
of
the war doesn't become look how russia
is using crypto to evade economic
sanctions that would be a very bad look
and it would echo the worries that some
government regulators have about crypto
which is that it's not responsible to
state control and of course that's you
know just a flip side of what one of the
things a lot of crypto advocates love
about crypto which is that it's not
subject to state control or at least at
present is not fully subject to state
control so to shift the narrative to
look how cleverly ukraine is using
crypto it's not exactly pr but it's a
clever spin
move both for the ukrainians and also
probably for for crypto advocates
to what extent
has the
[Music]
as as i understand it
let's just call it focus on
locking
down private banking certain types of
private banking tax havens for extremely
wealthy
russians let's just
say in
quotation marks oligarchs not all of
them would be certainly maybe considered
oligarchs but to some extent to try to
affect
the
inner circle those most
powerful private citizens
or perhaps not even solely private
within russia as a means of affecting
putin do you think that is pie in the
sky or do you think that could have
some bearing on
decision making or internal coups or
power dynamics within russia
the people who've been advocating for
that and have been carrying it out in
western capitals
are
realistic i think for the most part
behind closed doors
about recognizing that putin really
doesn't care
what happens to his rich buddies
and that his power over those oligarchs
is so great
that if he wants to take away their
money at least the money they have in
russia he does it anyway
and he's not afraid of the oligarchs
using that as a tool to bring him down
i mean he's done it before right he has
just arrested oligarchs and locked them
up including people who were
multi-multi-multi-billionaires
and he had zero worry it seemed
that that would weaken his
power or strength
so i am myself very skeptical and my
sense is that a lot of
experts who know much more about the way
russia operates internally than i do are
also really skeptical of this really
affecting putin
on the other hand it comes into the
category of
it might help yeah and what's the
downside
and you know the downside for a lot of
rich people who are not russian
oligarchs is that they look at this and
they say whoa wait a minute you know
have we entered a moment where
a country can freeze all of my assets
because they don't like something that
the government of the country that i'm
from is doing
you know you can imagine how high net
worth individuals would not like that
very much
you know because they're thinking what
if some country gets really mad at the
united states which happens are they
going to engage in these kinds of
sanctions that are targeted and directed
against us you know we club of poor
starving you know oppressed billionaires
and to put it a little more seriously
it's not in my view a great precedent to
be setting worldwide
that we're freezing your assets because
we don't like your government because
you might have an impact on what that
government does
so there are some downsides to it but i
think from the standpoint of sending a
message that we're doing everything we
can and also that we're not targeting
individual russians who are poor or
ordinary people
you can see the kind of policy
appeal of it and last but not least who
after all has a lot of sympathy for a
russian billionaire you know it's not
high on the list of people who you know
our hearts gonna go out to you know
we're not gonna all jump on board to
make donations to them so they're kind
of you know they're sort of like by
almost by definition they're the james
bond bad guys and they don't have a
powerful advocacy organization you know
drawing sympathy to them so you know i
myself have no sympathy for them but i'm
not sure that this kind of targeting
honestly really works all that well i
think to a significant degree it seems
that it doesn't so far
but it's relatively easy and it makes it
makes headlines
so a couple of points
maybe not points just observations for
folks so just to
paint a picture and please feel free to
fact check this noah if if i'm getting
things wrong but
if we
just take for the sake of discussion
putin as the world's first official
trillionaire
and then compare that to billionaires it
would be like
a
millionaire putting someone in jail who
has a few thousand dollars
right so just to draw kind of a power
contrast
if we use
money as a proxy for power certainly
putin has a lot more behind that
as well
and
a question i'd like to ask is
could one make a compelling argument
that putin did not miscalculate
and let me explain
and that his decision to invade was
rational in so much as similar to in the
u.s
if we look at the history of re-election
let's just say in the case of the u.s
that wartime presidents are
frequently re-elected
if domestic support for putin were
waning and he wanted to bolster that
could an argument be made that
protracting a battle in ukraine would
actually be to his benefit
in some form or fashion
because
i have read a decent amount about putin
he is not stupid
he's very
systematic
he's very aggressive
and
as easy as it might be
on some level for folks to try to paint
him as this lunatic who's looking for
the red button to smash with his fist
because he's
lost his marbles or has early onset
dementia or fill in the blank i don't
find that immediately compelling what
would uh you say to any of that
two great
issues there the first about
putin being more powerful than the
oligarchs and the second about whether
there's a rational calculus for
continuing the war let me take them one
at a time because they're both too good
to pass up so on the first one you're
right that putin is richer than his
oligarchs but i think that matters zero
for his power over them in the following
way
in the united states where we have a
pretty well functioning
property regime you know where basically
notwithstanding what a libertarian might
say the government doesn't take all your
money for no reason it does tax you but
it doesn't take all your money for no
reason we we do use money as a power
powerful proxy for
overall capacity to do stuff to have
power in our country it's obviously true
it also is connected to the way our
politics works right if you have a lot
of money you can fund a lot of political
movements you can in fact affect
politicians you can buy and sell in the
united states if you want to be powerful
the best thing you could be would be to
be super rich i i totally buy that
but it's not exactly like that in a
place like russia
where the president can
with
no need to answer to anybody else just
imprison the richest people
if you can lock somebody up it doesn't
matter how rich they are
right and it doesn't matter how rich you
are honestly i mean putin could be not
could not have he could have not chosen
to you know rob and steal from his
countrymen and his country to a massive
vast
fortune and he still would be powerful
as long as he could lock people up
and so in that sense
you know
for him the power stems from the barrel
of a gun and i think the takeaway of
that point is one that we sometimes
forget especially when we think about
crypto you know we think to ourselves
well if i have a lot of money and it's
in crypto and nobody then nobody can
take it away from me
and that's true unless they put you in
prison and tell you that they won't let
you out of prison unless you give them
the key to your wallet
and then if you don't want to be in
prison which most people don't really
want to be
you would give it up or they could
threaten to kill you in which case you
would definitely give it up
so
you know the capacity to govern me as a
person by putting me in prison
is so powerful that whoever has that
power can take whatever i have so that's
my first my first on you know what makes
putin so powerful it's not that he's
rich he's rich because he's powerful
he's not powerful because he's rich
and there's a as i said there's a
takeaway for that for you know anyone
who thinks oh you know the inevitable
reality is that
money governs all it's not inevitable
money only governs all if the government
allows it to
then there's your question about is
there some rational way to explain
putin keeping the war going and here i
would say yes and no
i think that he did probably calculate
when he went to war that he thought he'd
win the war fast
but if he didn't
he wasn't going to immediately be
overthrown in a coup
because he could regroup and reorient
the war to a more achievable objective
and that's exactly what he did
right i think his first preference was
to take down ukraine right away and put
in a puppet government and have it be an
enormous grand victory and that's why he
started the war by going after
all of ukraine i mean that's why he made
a run for the capital and that explains
the military strategy that was adopted
at first
and that just didn't work or it didn't
work the way he wanted it to work but he
didn't then say i'm done
because then he would have had to admit
that he lost the war
and he didn't want to do that because
that would reflect weakness
and so he defaulted to what a lot of
people expected him to do in the first
place which is just go after
you know these two provinces
in one region and focus on getting those
and then if he wins that he can say
that's all i ever wanted and that was a
victory and i think he can reason that
at least if he can win that war in some
reasonable period of time
the russian public will either put up
with it or ultimately be happy about it
and so he still it makes sense for him
to keep on fighting with that more
limited objective in mind he also might
have in the back of his mind last of all
that if he does win that province
then he can consolidate take a deep
breath and then decide if he wants to go
back and do the whole thing again
going for all of ukraine and if ukraine
is worried about that which they should
be
ukraine within a reason to say okay just
take these two provinces and be done
with it and we're willing to resolve the
war
and that leads me to my final comment on
this which is a genuine worry
which is what's gonna happen if that
happens right what's gonna happen if
putin says okay i want to keep these two
provinces and ukraine says zolensky says
okay
you know we're done we lost a lot of
people we know we can't win these
provinces back from you
and we're a little scared that you might
come after us and we don't want to take
that risk so the war is over
what's the rest of the world going to do
right is the united states then going to
be able to just say okay well it's up to
ukraine it's your country
is europe going to be able to do that
because the message that that's sending
to the world is still hey if putin wants
some provinces of your country he can
come and get them
so the rest of the world the u.s europe
we're in pretty deep on this
arguing that russia should lose the war
so you could imagine a scenario
it's actually a possible scenario
where the ukrainians say we're ready to
be done with the war
but the west is saying no we don't want
you to give up because we're you know so
concerned about the message that this
sent so it's not too soon to start
worrying about that end game and i for
one am actually really worried about it
because i don't want this to be
somewhere that goes on forever
not because i want putin to win i want
him to lose but because if he can win in
a limited way i don't want the whole
world to be caught up in this war and
ukrainian people to be caught up in this
war longer than the ukrainians wanted to
go on that seems like a mistake
i have a number of follow-on questions
that i would love to get your take on so
first
we talked about
freezing assets or rather you mentioned
and i asked about freezing assets
earlier
do you think any of the decisions
by the us
could
in terms of negatively affecting
usd reserves united us dollar reserves
in other
countries
end up in some way devaluing
the
united states dollar as the reserve
currency of the world in other words do
you think any of the decisions that the
us government has made or could make
could lead central banks and
other such groups to change how they
think about the composition of their
reserve currencies
there's one decision the us has made
that is super high risk in this
realm in my view
and it's the decision to freeze assets
that russia owns
in the united states that are dollar
assets and not let russia use them
to pay off its own sovereign debt
thereby forcing russia to default on the
money that it owes to its creditors
now why is that risky it's risky because
russia is not the only country that owes
money to people
in the form of sovereign debt
that keeps its money in the united
states to pay back some of that debt
and that's in fact one of the reasons
that the dollar is a reserve currency
because people are confident that if
they hold their money in a u.s bank in
dollars it'll hold on to its value and
they'll be able to use it to pay back
their creditors and so if countries
realize that under some circumstances
their dollar assets in the us
can be frozen for
political moral reasons and that they
won't be allowed to pay off their own
creditors with that money
that should make them think hard
about whether they want to keep their
money in dollars
in a u.s bank
for purposes of
paying other people back
now the reason that
the people in the treasury department
who think most deeply and hard about
this
haven't concluded that the us shouldn't
do this that the us shouldn't freeze
these assets in a way that makes russia
default
is that they're calculating
and you know they're smart people
they're calculating
that
the dollar is still so stable and strong
relative to other possible
currencies that people can hold
that people will still countries will
still maintain their large reserves in
dollars
they'll just say okay well let's not
invade any other countries and they'll
say oh that's only happening to russia
because it did this extreme behavior
but the reason i think that's actually a
pretty substantial gambit or risk
is that
once we've done this once and gotten
away with it the temptation is going to
be there
you know the temptation is going to be
there to do this again to other
countries we don't like
justice robert jackson on the supreme
court said in the famous kuromatsu case
which was the case about the internment
of japanese americans that if the court
upholds that internment which he didn't
want it to do
then the principle that you can do
something like this lies around like a
loaded weapon
you know and if you don't want a little
weapon lying around because someone
might use it under other circumstances
and i think that's the worry here that
this kind of
freezing assets and not letting them
countries use them to pay off their own
debts
is it going to be a very tempting thing
for us policymakers to use as leverage
in the future and if we were to get into
that habit
over time under different circumstances
that i think probably would have the
effect
of undermining confidence
in people holding their dollars in the
united states what do you think
the
base case scenario is let's just call it
likely outcome
is for ukraine russia conflict and
what do you think some of the
worst case scenarios are that aren't one
in a million likelihood but
higher probability and i'm leaving out
the best case deliberately because i
think the secret to happiness is low
expectations
and
how's that working out for you tim
it actually works out pretty well i
asked just a side note the reason that i
hate
reason i say that is i i think it's
necessary but not sufficient and so much
as
i read some national geographic poll who
knows how
reliable that is but an article that
described the happiest countries in the
world and they were
denmark costa rica and singapore for
different reasons and i asked a danish
friend of mine why he thought that was
the case and he said low expectations so
i just have latched on to that
so you went with it i just went with it
by the way we should someday have a long
conversation about that i think that the
question of whether this it's like
resolve that resolve that the secret to
happiness is low expectations is a
completely fascinating topic to to talk
about sometime but anyway going back to
ukraine and worst case scenarios and
base case like if you were a betting man
like what would you bet on i'll start
with the base case then yeah
my base case is that
over time russia will successfully
conquer
the these two provinces the donbas
region which is made up of these two
provinces which have a lot of russian
speakers in them
and that ukraine will realize that it
can't really defend those provinces
and then there'll be a pause might be a
brief pause it might be a longer pause
where everyone tries to figure out what
happens next
and
in that scenario
there will be suggestions of peace talks
in which russia ends up holding on to
those provinces by the way in the same
way that it still has crimea
which it took over with a lot less
trouble years ago and which ukraine
conceded to and the rest of the world
didn't support ukraine in fighting back
and the world has already established
the principle that russia can grab
substantial parts of ukraine so this
would just be a little more of ukraine
so some people will be saying we're not
setting a new president because we
already have the precedent in place
and so the war should just be ended on
these terms
and you know i think the base case is
that ukraine's leadership at that point
would say yeah you know we want this war
to be over
we survived existentially there's still
a country called ukraine
and
we want
to give up those provinces but we also
want to join nato and we want to be
have the guarantee from nato that at
least the rest of our country will never
be taken down and then negotiations
proceed on that basis
now what makes that
hard that base case hard
in reality in practice is that the
russians are going to say you can't be
in nato
and the ukraine's gonna say we need to
be in nato and then ukraine's are also
gonna say want to be in the eu which
until now to be blunt the europeans
wouldn't have wanted them in the eu but
now because the europeans are so worried
about sending a message to russia
they're suddenly saying okay well now
we're willing to talk to you about maybe
being in the eu
and russia's not going to want that
either
so russia is going to say you can't have
these two things that you want
and we want to hold on to this territory
ukraine's going to say well if you want
us to let you keep that territory you
have to agree to these other things
and so it may be that those negotiations
in which you could imagine a rational
person saying okay that's what's going
to happen
ukraine in nato ukraine and the eu but
ukraine no longer has this whole region
anymore
and russia now effectively owns that you
can imagine that being a rational
outcome but actually negotiating to that
conclusion is really hard to pull off on
both sides
and for that reason
the sort of to my mind next most likely
scenario is that the state of war would
continue
even if the active hostilities weren't
ongoing
and that could really last
a long time and so that's the not at all
implausible variant on the base case
that is to my mind the scariest
because it's expensive to run a war the
energy
consequences of that
have already begun to be felt in europe
and in the rest of the world at a moment
when the global economy is looking
pretty precarious
keeping energy prices artificially high
as a consequence of this ongoing war and
of the sanctions associated with it is
not good
for the global economy at all
and so you could imagine a scenario
where this as it were just gets beyond
us where neither side is capable of
reaching the compromise that would be
the quote-unquote rational compromise
and that as a consequence this just goes
on for a long time and if you say oh
that that couldn't happen
lots of wars go on for a really really
long time sometimes at a low level
sometimes at a less low level because
they don't have a clear model for
resolving them and they can go on for
years and so that's the thing that
scares me the most
that's my totally plausible variant on
the base case and i will say that some
of my friends who are you know full-time
international affairs analysts think
that that's the base case
you know they think that the base cases
that it just keeps on going until
somebody blinks
and some of them think that ultimately
putin would blink but a lot of them
think no like neither side's gonna blink
and it could just really go on
indefinitely and so the fact that
there's some really thoughtful smart
people who think that's the base case
really really really scares me
you mentioned international affairs
analysts
and
i would like to know from your
perspective do any books come to mind or
people
who you find or that you find
particularly interesting
or informative with respect to
geopolitical strategy
brinksmanship on this geopolitical
three-dimensional chess board or warfare
in any capacity for people who would
like to get a better understanding of
how these games are played maybe
historical precedence how different
conflicts
have turned out depending on different
stratagems used by opposing parties for
instance
any books or people
you find
interesting
yeah so one is something that a lot of
listeners will have heard of maybe all
listeners will have heard of and some
will have read especially people who are
veterans and definitely people who have
been in the service academies will have
read and it's not that long and it's
unbelievably good and it's this book
called on war
by von klausewitz a german general
it's the single most influential book on
war written since
sun tzu's art of war
and
as i said it's required reading in
military academies in every country in
the world
it's shockingly well written
it's unbelievably clear
and it has a very specific philosophical
view about what war is like and what war
is for and it's famous for the line that
war is the continuation of politics by
other means
and
that's a profound statement
because it suggests that war
serves the interests of political actors
and is prosecuted to achieve those
interests
but the other thing about it that's
really fascinating is he wrote it from
the point of view that says the only
smart way to fight a war is to fight it
absolutely
without holding back
put all your chips on the table and try
to win the war
and
that maximizes the odds that you will
and it'll be over faster and if it's
over faster that's also good for
everybody he says because then it won't
kill more people and eat up more
resources
and yet despite the fact that the first
idea of fun class of it's the idea that
wars politics by other means is accepted
by everybody in the domain of foreign
politics
there are lots of words that aren't
fought in the extreme all-out fun class
of its
wet tons of them including a bunch of
u.s wars which have not been fought that
way
wars which notably we haven't won
you know wars like vietnam and iraq and
arguably even afghanistan
so i would strongly recommend that book
i can't actually recommend it strongly
enough
it really makes you think
and they're you know it's easy to buy
you can buy it in any bookshop and i'm
sure you could buy it on amazon you know
in 20 seconds
in terms of contemporary people
writing about the geopolitics you know i
really like to mix and match
i
like to read work by
people who are thought of as realists
who think that national self-interest is
all that matters and i like to read work
by people who are called idealists who
think that moral principles matter as
well and i really like historical
perspective so on anything to do with
ukraine
i love the work of a historian called
tim snyder who teaches at yale
and
he's
first of all a fantastic historian who's
genuinely a ukraine expert i mean his
first few books before he got famous
were highly technical historical studies
of ukrainian history
and then each book he writes gets a
little broader in terms of its audience
and now he writes very broad in general
books
and he's a terrific historian and he's
really the person to read on ukraine and
its history
and he also takes you beyond just
ukraine
and discusses the relationship between
germany and russia
and
really the whole 20th century's concept
of war
which interestingly he thinks of ukraine
as having been at the middle of not
because ukraine was so important but
because the countries germany and russia
that were fighting these wars were
fighting in part over the territory that
includes ukraine so i would strongly
recommend any of his books his grand
book is called bloodlands
it's
long
and
intense but it's very very very
beautifully and and clearly written and
if you can you know if you can stomach a
book about the wars of the 20th century
you'll learn a ton about geopolitics and
the region in the process
thank you for those recommendations
sounds like i have some fun classifieds
to read
first and foremost you're going to love
on class events
he would totally be on your podcast if
you were still alive
i wanted to mention one which is is
going to be a bit of a risk for me to
mention simply because i haven't read it
although i have some familiarity with
the author and have watched a number of
presentations by the author and the
reason i would mention such a book
without having read it is that it has
come up again and again in conversation
with friends of mine who are in
intelligence or formerly from
intelligence or
let's just call it high-level military
and not just in the u.s
so this book has been widely translated
and
i know it is also read very widely in
china just as an example
by military and this is a book called
coup d'etat a practical handbook
by edward n lutvak i'm imagining that's
how you pronounce it l-u-t-t-w-a-k
and
it was originally published in 1968 but
here's the description on amazon has 127
ratings this is not a mainstream i
wouldn't say book but it is very well
reviewed i have not read it again so i
can't vouch for it but the opening
description is kudatas astonished
readers when it first appeared in 1968
because it showed step by step how
governments could be overthrown
translated into 16 languages dot dot dot
it has inspired anti-coup precautions by
regimes around the world so that would
be maybe a partial explanation for why
the chinese officials and military would
be interested in this and it goes on and
on so that
also i can't personally recommend but it
has been recommended to be by many many
folks it's 300 pages 304 pages long
so about 10 years ago i
wrote a book about u.s and china which
was called cool war which i thought was
like the best title of any book title
i've ever come up with and
i was convinced that i'd come up with
the perfect name for the us-china
relationship because
my whole argument in the book was at the
time the western china were getting
along really well
but their geopolitical interests were
diverging even though their economic
interests were still overlapping and so
my whole argument was this is going to
change because our geopolitical
disagreements are going to get deeper
and deeper and deeper
but i said we're not going to start
shooting at each other because that
would literally be insane
and so what we need is a word for a
situation where
there are two global superpowers
that are the two poles
but they still cooperate economically
and there are all kinds of names going
on at the time people were saying oh
it's not cooperation it's co-option you
know people have all kinds of names for
enemies with benefits
exactly
benefits and a very senior strategist at
harvard wrote the called the thucydides
trap
raising the question of whether china
and the us would inevitably go to war
and i was like no they're not going to
inevitably go to war but it's going to
be like the cold war but not as cold so
i came up with this idea of cool war
and it was a very hawkish book at the
time
extremely hawkish it was liked by the
hawks on both sides and that led me to
an exchange with lutvac could you just
for people wondering could you explain
just in this sense what do you mean by
hawkish
in general in these kind of foreign
affairs situations if you're saying
that two countries should get along and
we'll get along you're a dove
you know you're you may not be a pure
peacenik but you're a dove in the sense
that you're kind of soft and sweet
but if you're saying the two countries
are likely to
be increasingly opposed to each other
and need to treat each other as though
they might come to blows and need to
build up their militaries to keep an eye
on each other then you're a hawk
that is to say you know your talents are
out and
you're prepared for a conflict and
for me it was sort of a surprise to find
out that i at the end of writing this
book that i had written a pretty hawkish
book not saying the us and china would
go to war but they had to act towards
each other as though their interests
were going to increasingly diverge and i
even suggested maybe the economic
getting along wasn't going to continue
indefinitely either and i even said in
there that they're
imagine a populist leader on either the
u.s side or the china side or both that
would really i obviously didn't think of
donald trump in that role that would
really lead to a fundamental divergence
and so i ended up writing this book that
sort of was very hard-nosed with respect
to jio strategy
and so i got into conversation with
ludvac because he is a strategist
strategist
and he had written a lot of really
interesting and i thought smart things
about u.s china relations in exactly
this vein so we had a whole exchange and
it was very positive and i actually
thought we were going to end up meeting
and talking but then something went
wrong i can't remember exactly what it
was but i think he just lost interest in
the whole the whole thing
and so i you know that was what i was
thinking about but i've read a lot of
his work
and
he is a sharp writer and he is sort of
the ultimate
rationalist machiavellian writer you
know when he's writing about power he's
writing about power and he doesn't think
that moral considerations should come
into the conversation when you're doing
that power talk
well perhaps i'll have to have him on
the podcast he has been nicknamed the
machiavelli of maryland to explain
more of his position but you're right he
is
very
cut and dry
pure power strategy
some levels i haven't read his book so i
shouldn't say that definitively but in
the talks that i've seen
i find it interesting and unusual
because i haven't been exposed much to
that to hear it so plainly said if that
makes sense and tbd to be continued i
suggest we
segue to free speech on social media so
this is this is something you track very
closely
and
there are a number of notes out in front
of me you know texas and florida have
passed laws banning the platforms
various platforms from moderating
content
elon is against twitter content
moderation supposedly you know spotify
has
taken down some backlist from joe rogan
and there are a lot of open questions
related to this and i think a lot of
perhaps
undefined terms and other issues that we
can explore so where would where would
you like to begin with free speech on
social media
well let me begin personally just with
the disclosure which is that
having helped what was then facebook
make its oversight board i still advise
meta on free speech issues and i also
sometimes advise other social media
companies like tick tock
and so i'm not i'm not going to claim to
be wholly objective about this that said
i
try very hard and i think this is why
i'm of use when i do advise
to not tell anybody what they want to
hear so what i'm going to say is just me
talking
and it's what i
what i actually believe
so i guess what i think is
most fascinating is that we're at a
really interesting inflection point
about free speech and social media
associated with elon musk's
proposed twitter takeover and you and i
have been
both very fascinated to watch and see
whether that would actually happen in
the end and maybe you want to share your
grand theory about it tim but in any
case what's fascinating about it is that
in
saying he's going to take take over
twitter and take it private musk has not
said
i'm doing this
because i think this is a great business
and i'm really good at business
and i can make a company run well and i
think there's a lot of money to be made
in it
nor has he said you know i think it'd be
really cool to do x which is one of the
things he does say usually i mean that's
sort of the spacex theory it would be
really cool to do x and i can make money
at it
instead he expressed for i think the
first time at least in his public
business career
a kind of
free speech related values-based view he
basically said i don't think it's good
that
twitter limits people's free speech
through content moderation and i want to
change that
so that's a pretty substantial reason to
spend 40 billion dollars even if you had
at the time
you know maybe three or four times that
i'm not sure he still does but even if
he had at the time three or four times
that that's a pretty fascinating
motivation it's a really different kind
of motivation and it's not only unusual
for him it's unusual for anybody
you know we we might expect you know
jeff bezos to buy the washington post
but that did not cost any 40 billion
dollars for him to buy you know or to
sustain you know that's a relatively
small purchase from the standpoint of
someone you know with a with a ton of
money so
the moment that we're in is a moment
where
the idea that content moderation is a
problem for free speech is getting a lot
of air time
and where simultaneously on the other
side
you've got the idea that the deep
platforming of donald trump from
effectively all of the major social
media outlets at the time
was something that remains supported
by many many liberals in the political
spectrum
notwithstanding that it's hard to
imagine a greater violation of the
principle of free speech
than that the guy who was present in the
united states then and remains
you know the most popular politician on
the republican side can't speak
through these platforms especially given
that the guy donald trump made his
reputation to some significant degree
using twitter so we've got sort of the
two extreme positions
arrayed here and what we don't have is a
lot of clarity about the terms
on which this fight should be played out
so i can say more about that by the way
if you want i was just pausing so i
don't go on for too long yeah please say
more and i would also just love to know
if we're dealing with
a wide spectrum
of
definitions for free speech
or if it's free speech in quotation
marks with other motives
at play you don't have to speak to that
right now but i would like to explore
that totally that's exactly where i was
going to go great let's go there because
i think i like many people are like well
wait a second like what this person is
calling free speech
is not i think what one would find the
perhaps legal or constitutional
definition to be and then what this
person is calling free speech is really
driven by this motivated reasoning
around what they want or some financial
outcome or who knows what so i'd love
you to expand on that
your insight tim is actually i think the
single most important starting point for
figuring out what's going on in this
debate right now
and it's that we can't define what free
speech is unless we dig down a little
bit underneath the slogan
so free speech has two different
meanings basically
one meaning is the ordinary meaning of
the term
which means something like i get to say
what i want
to whom i want when i want to say it
and that would include my saying it on
social media and if i'm d platform from
social media or if my post is taken away
because it violates
the terms of service or community
standards of a particular
social media platform then under that
ordinary meaning of free speech my free
speech has been limited i can't i can't
talk in the place in a way that i want
to talk
then there's what you might call the
lawyer's definition of free speech or
the constitutional definition of free
speech and that's really narrow
what that says is that under the first
amendment to the us constitution
the government can't stop me from
speaking
but only the government
a private party can stop me from
speaking
so the example i i always use with my
con law students though they maybe
irritated me for doing this is i point
out that if you teach constitutionalize
your day job like i do your kids at a
very early age tell you when they you
tell them to be quiet that they have
free speech rights
so my son i don't i don't know how old
he was when he said that but very very
young you know maybe five or something
and i explained to him then and you know
for a couple of years afterwards that he
actually didn't have free speech rights
visa v me he only had free speech rights
relative to the government but i could
tell him to shut up and i could give him
consequences if he didn't you know
closes now if they're not say or do a
particular thing and he didn't like that
very much but i think for my students
it's a good way to remember the
constitutional definition it's the
reason you can tell someone to shut up
without violating the constitution and
similarly under that constitutional
definition
so far at least and i'm gonna go there
in a moment but so far at least
if a social media platform which is a
private company
which has its own constitutional rights
tells one of its users you can't say
that or we're kicking you off the
platform it the social media platform
has a constitutional free speech right
to say we don't want to carry your
speech
and you the user have zero
constitutional rights
vis-a-vis the social media platform so
notice right away that that's a
completely different definition of free
speech and it's one that's just focused
on the government
what's fascinating what's really
fascinating is that that second
constitutional norm is under some
pressure because there are now some
supreme court justices
at least two probably three
who have been telegraphing in short
opinions not in full supreme court
opinions but in short opinions
that they think
that the idea of constitutional free
speech should be reinterpreted
so that
the social media companies
can't
regulate all of the speech on their
platforms and claim the protection of
the first amendment when they do so
and those justices are conservative
justices have a really interesting
set of arguments
arguments that
four or five years ago liberals kind of
liked but then liberals gave up on them
but now conservatives like them
and those arguments basically say
something like this
a ton of our conversation is happening
on social media
maybe we should analogize social media
companies to
a common carrier like a telephone
company telephone wire company which
can't pick and choose who's allowed to
get a telephone and who isn't allowed to
get a telephone based on what they're
going to say over their telephone or
maybe they should be thought of as
public accommodations
sort of like
a chain of hotels which can't say we're
not letting you stay in our hotel
because we don't like you
that would be discrimination and it
would be
unlawful and so those justices are
saying we should reconceptualize the
social media platforms is more like one
of those two things
either like a common carrier or like a
public accommodation and we should allow
the government
to pass laws that say they can't
discriminate on the basis of viewpoint
and the state of texas because they like
to be out ahead that was a joke
the state of texas passed such a law
they have in fact passed such a law
they passed the law saying it wasn't a
very funny joke they passed a law saying
that social media companies with more
than a certain number of users i think
was 50 million users or something like
that so the big social media companies
cannot take down any content based on
the viewpoint expressed
by the social media company
and of course the social media platforms
and others immediately went to court to
get that law blocked
and the first court said okay we're
going to block the law then the court of
appeals said we're reinstating the law
and then the supreme court by a very
close vote by a five to four vote said
the law is not going to go into
operation
while the lower courts figure out if
it's constitutional or not so that legal
court case is ongoing and it's going to
be really really really
important
because it goes to this core question of
whether those two different definitions
of free speech should remain
pulls apart two different definitions or
whether they should come together
and become a single definition of what
counts as free speech
two questions the first is why did
liberals
broadly speaking like
the arguments that you described a
handful of years ago
how did they differ perhaps from what
you just described and why did they give
up on them
yeah this is a fascinating and for
liberals embarrassing story i would say
for free speech liberals of whom i am
one by the way so
you know i i'm when i say it's
embarrassing for free speech liberals
i'm including myself in this
so take yourself back in time five or
six years
to when social media
was getting extremely powerful as a way
of people expressing themselves but
donald trump had not yet emerged as
a major
political phenomenon in the united
states so maybe you have to go back
seven years
at that time
free speech liberals were really worried
about the following
thing
they in theory like free speech
and yet they saw
that
a lot of the speech that was happening
on political subjects and other subjects
in the united states was happening on a
handful of platforms that were
controlled by a handful of very rich
people
and they were worried that that meant
that you know facebook as it was then
for example or twitter would come close
to having a kind of monopoly on public
discussion and public discourse
and liberals are worried about
monopolies they don't like monopolies
and they were worried about what would
happen if say
the people who ran facebook or the
people who ran twitter put a thumb on
the scale
of public debate
and had the effect
of
pushing public opinion
in their favor direction whatever that
favor direction would be
so that looks to liberals like a kind of
corporate control
and it scared them
furthermore
liberals hated a supreme court case
called the citizens united case
in which the supreme court had said
that corporations have free speech
rights now for a long time citizens
united was the most hated case by
liberals
because liberals were saying wait a
minute if corporations have free speech
rights and they can spend money on
election campaigns
and affect the outcomes and that's
terrible because it gives corporations a
disproportionate amount of power because
corporations exist to amass capital and
to make money
and so since liberals hated the citizens
united decision and the citizens united
decision was the one that said that
corporations have free speech rights
liberals laughed at the idea that
corporations like facebook or twitter
should have free speech rights so there
were multiple reasons for liberals to be
super super super skeptical of what was
going on
then here's what happened
some
progressive groups
started lobbying the social media
companies successfully
to start
doing much more aggressive content
moderation
and limiting or eliminating
hate speech of various kinds
and harassment of various kinds
and those groups again were coming from
a progressive point of view so they were
saying
you know
we don't just want you twitter or
facebook to stop
allowing meanness they were saying we
don't want meanness on the basis of sex
meanness on the basis of race meanness
on the basis of sexual orientation
so
those kinds of concerns were
desirable from the standpoint of
liberals and it started to work and the
social media companies upped their
degree of content moderation
in a way that
liberals started to like
because discourse on those platforms
then became in certain ways more civil
less discriminatory and less nasty
than general public discourse say on
internet 1.0
would have been
and at the same time
conserve some as with the rise of trump
some extreme conservatives started
advocating violence and other things
like that and those are things that the
platforms also were taking down and so
liberals were also eager to see those
things taken down
and so liberals reconsidered their prior
position
that these companies
should be subject to
regulation and restriction
and maybe even controlled by the first
amendment because if they were
controlled by the first amendment they
wouldn't be able to take down
racist speech or sexist speech
and they wouldn't be able to de-platform
people because they were abstractly
advocating for violence
so the liberals flipped and then when
you know it the conservatives flipped
too
the conservatives who had been saying
whatever these are corporations they
have rights corporations have rights
they can do whatever they want it's
their business let them do whatever they
want with it you know let the market
decide if you want a different content
moderation strategy let a rich person
buy the business like elon musk may be
buying twitter right so that was the
conservative position but the
conservatives flipped and they started
saying oh no these social media
platforms are skewing liberal in terms
of their content moderation policies and
we don't want that so we would like to
impose the first amendment on them or
impose regulation on them
so that they will have to allow the
speech that we are promoting which
happens to include speech that they
consider to be racist or sexist or
advocating violence so we got this in my
opinion extremely embarrassing 180
degree flip on both sides
about the regulation of social media
which happens sometimes in
constitutional affairs it happens in
free speech and i think everybody should
be very embarrassed by people on both
sides
so i'd like to bring up maybe the same
question that
we explored on
ukraine and that is the stakes
what is at stake here and if you
flash forward
and i understand that there's no crystal
ball here so it's just
guesstimation based on
the facts at hand
three years from now or five you can
pick the time frame
what's at stake and what would you say
are the base case
and uh could be best case you can
include best case if you like i know
i'll reverse my scandinavian orientation
on that one
and
then possibly
uh worst case and and i'll throw one
more element which you can choose to
address or we can leave aside for now
and that is
is there a possibility that the
definition of hate speech metastasizes
and broadens in such a way to serve very
particular
silencing objectives right where there's
a certain suppressive effect
on desired groups by
categorizing as hate speech even
commentary op-eds etc
that ask questions related to topics
that are deemed sensitive or offensive
fill in the blank to a particular group
so what are the stakes and then what do
you think things might look like three
to five years from now
the stakes are really huge
because
they go to the question of where we're
going to talk to each other
what we're going to say to each other
and
how politics is going to interface
with the online universe and the online
universe is not going away you know it's
going to continue to be
in expanded ways
the central way that we communicate
about tons and tons
of subjects so the stakes couldn't be
higher and they're really high on both
sides
they're high for people broadly speaking
on the left who are worried that january
6 style
extremism
could go from being peripheral in the
united states to mainstream
with dire consequences for democracy
and they're consequential to people on
the right who are worried as you were
sort of hinting
that
principles of
limiting speech to avoid what counts as
quote-unquote hate speech or political
correctness
could actually impede
public debate
and discourse in a way that's really
destructive because it means that
certain points of view can't be heard
and if they can't be heard then they're
de-legitimated and then potentially
harmed
so the stakes are huge and they're huge
on both sides
can the definition of hate speech be
expanded in a way to suppress certain
political points of view
not only is the answer yes but that's
really why the concept of hate speech
was invented in the first place
you know in especially germany but
elsewhere in europe after world war ii
in the aftermath of the rise of nazism
lots of moderate centrist people thought
wait what went wrong in our society
you know i mean germany had a liberal
constitution in the 1920s
and it had all kinds of economic
problems and all kinds of struggle
between different political parties but
it had a nominally ordinary liberal
constitution
and in that environment communists were
able to express their views nazis were
able to express their views and
ultimately
that liberal democracy failed and was
replaced by the nazi state and so
centrist moderate said we really need to
rethink the idea that free speech lets
you express all kinds of views including
nazi views because people might believe
those views
and so the idea of prohibiting certain
kinds of speech certain kinds of hate
speech was based on the worry
that in europe it could happen here
because it had just happened there
that that kind of
talking had led to action and had led to
the collapse of constitutional
government
so the whole point of outlining certain
kinds of hate speech was to prohibit
certain kinds of political views from
gaining the kind of foothold that would
lead them to take power it was different
in the us
in the u.s
the free speech movement in the 20s
tended to take the view in the 30s tend
to take the view that oliver wendell
holmes jr one of the most famous supreme
court justices took where he said
listen you can't shout fire in a crowded
theater so there are some limits
if you're about to overthrow the
government in the next few moments
yes we can shut you up
but he said if through calm reasonable
conversation
the ultimate effect of speech is to
bring about
he said the dictatorship of the
proletariat you know a victory of
soviet-style communism he said i think
my job is to let that happen
that's his most extreme formulation in
favor of free speech but it's damn
extreme and he said it in a supreme
court opinion and so that was the kind
of absolutist view that said as long as
you're not about to
imminently cause violence
you can say whatever you want and if
that undermines our political norms
that's fine
so from that point of view from that
holmesian point of view
in the us
we really
shouldn't want it to be the case
that prohibitions on hate speech end up
really limiting what you can say in
public
that's the kind of strong pro-free
speech view
the worry is are we in a place where
germany was
in the 20s you know are is january 6 the
kind of historical event that shows you
that there's a genuine risk
that people could try to overthrow the
government
of the united states and you know as
more details come out not just about
january 6 but about donald trump's
various efforts to try to reverse the
outcome of the election
there is a point of view that says
that's not so crazy you know our
democracy maybe is in greater danger
than it's been at in the past and maybe
for that reason speech should be limited
so i think what's hardest about this
problem is a lot of what you think
depends on how you assess our real world
situation
do you actually believe
that we're in danger of enough people
getting on board
with dangerous bad crazy ideas
and breaking our democracy
that you need to do things like d
platform donald trump
or do you think look we're fine you know
sure january 6 was terrible but that was
only a relatively small number of people
and donald trump didn't succeed in
overthrowing the outcome of the election
and we shouldn't mess with our basic
free speech norms which have served us
so well
until now
so that leaves the question of the the
base case
to me the the most probable
outcome
is that
we continue to have
a pretty robust
system of private actors including
newspapers and social media platforms
and others
limiting speech
pretty extensively
but we also have some other social media
actors whether it turns out to be
twitter or some startup social media
entity that have totally different rules
that are much closer to ordinary free
speech rules that are much closer to the
idea that you can say whatever you want
and then we would get a more expanded
ecosystem
in which
if you really want to say something to a
lot of people you're going to find some
venue in which you can say it
and my guess is again more probable than
not that if the market does that the
courts will then back away from
speculating about maybe whether they
should step in to intervene
and limit and allow a limitation of what
these social media companies
do and that's because i just don't think
it's sustainable in the long run
that half or even you know 35
of the public is supporting someone for
president
and that person has no major social
media outlet i just don't think that's
practically
probable or realistic either the social
media outlets or some social medias will
shift to allow that kind of speech
or new social media outlets will come
into existence or someone will buy one
of the existing ones and flip it so in
those scenarios there will be some
mechanism
for all kinds of speech to get out there
and then the us will probably ultimately
preserve at least the core of our free
speech tradition probably
but that's just the base case you know
you could imagine it you can imagine it
going the other way in that you can
imagine the government intervening
and saying we're gonna have much more
aggressive requirements
passed by state legislatures or others
that say that the social media companies
can't silence
hate speech and then what would happen
is we would sort of go back to internet
1.0 where you really could say anything
you wanted somewhere on the internet and
you could be as nasty as you wanted and
you could be as dangerous as you wanted
no one could really do anything about it
so that that is also a possible scenario
that could
that could potentially emerge it may be
that the social media platforms with
their central dominance over so much of
our speech will turn out to have been an
artifact of a certain moment
in the history of the web you know web
2.0 moment and in a web 3.0 moment maybe
they just won't matter as much even if
they continue to use the kinds of
content moderation standards that they
presently have
so i have a number of
maybe mundane
logistics slash plumbing questions for
you you'll see where this is going
in the the two questions are just asking
as a
purely naive politically illiterate
person
if state
is passed let's just say texas says
social media companies past
x number of users need to behave in the
following way how does that actually
play out and work functionally right is
there just geo-fencing where suddenly
twitter is turned off in texas like the
great firewall of china that's question
number one and then number two is
and i i understand that web3 and
decentralization is a huge topic we
could we could explore separately and
that may be the answer but
how
realistic is
it to have
the sort of free market argument that
there will be players who can strain
free speech there will be players who do
not constrain free speech and the
fittest will survive if
many of those which will begin as
startups are dependent on infrastructure
that is centralized and rented from a
company like amazon with aws for
instance
to which a lot of pressure can be
applied as a choke point so those are
the two questions
on the first one the the sort of
technical point if you ask people for
the big social media platforms could you
just turn off service in texas tomorrow
they say no
they say that's too hard for us to do
right now
and they it's not just me saying that
they say that they said that in court
papers
my sense is that it is a technically
hard problem
it's also my sense that sometimes
technically hard problems can find a
solution if they're absolutely
obligatory and you do wonder how
texans would feel if tomorrow they
couldn't get twitter
or they couldn't get you know facebook
or instagram or tick tock in
the state of texas now maybe they would
discover that that was a new utopia in
fact i have a fantasy if that happened i
think i might move to texas i think it
would be kind of great if i couldn't use
any of those things i had enforced you
know forced protection i just saw this
is relevant to this i just saw a study
in a journal
a scholarly journal suggesting that just
having your phone with you in the room
even if it is off
makes you dumber on a whole bunch of
testable criteria
just having it in the room not having it
on not using it but just having it in
the room the only way to get that away
apparently is to keep it in another room
so you know maybe other people share my
fantasy of a world where suddenly we
didn't have to do any of those things
but in any case if texans didn't feel
that way
they might really be unhappy with that
law i mean i think the reason texas is
passing that law is the state
legislature is sort of assuming that it
won't be possible to turn off those
services in their state
and therefore that they could bind
the social media platforms right now if
you're turkey and you say
listen we demand that
you know twitter
shut up somebody who's a critic of our
government twitter reserves the right to
say okay we're just going to turn off
our service in your country
the question is you know could that so
if that could be done in turkey maybe it
can be done in texas by some means and
mechanisms that might be one way that
that plays out but at present the social
media platforms say it's too hard so
that's the first question
the second question was how realistic is
it to expect that you could have
survival of the fittest with some
startups or established incumbent social
media companies
with respect to that
question
a lot of it turns on
how much in web 3.0 things change versus
staying the same so one thing that we
saw in the aftermath of the trump d
platforming
is that
sites like 4chan and 8chan
and other
kinds of social media platforms
that
were under criticism for allowing
various kinds of
speech that was considered to be
repulsive in the aftermath of january
6th
had a problem on their hands which is
that they did have to be hosted by
centralized infrastructure and huge
pressure was brought on the centralized
infrastructure to cut them off
and so that actually led to the taking
down of a bunch of significant
services
and so
if we were to see a continuation of that
structure
then i think
the idea of decentralization won't work
you know the idea that don't worry
there's something that can be said
somewhere on the web won't work because
it still will be possible to go to
whoever controls the infrastructure at
different layers i mean it could be
amazon at the aws service it could be
apple and google at the app store level
exactly so
as long as that kind of centralized
infrastructure remains in place i think
you're a hundred percent correct that it
isn't a solution to enabling their
speech
if that's what you want to do to say
well
they can save them their views somewhere
however here's where a kind of web 3.0
scenario of true true or
decentralization
might make a substantial difference
if
those kinds of services hosting services
and other services were to follow a path
that some web 3.0
analysts and advocates
either and expect or hope that it will
of radical radical decentralization so
that there's no one in the middle
controlling large parts of the
infrastructure of the web
then it would be
a solution because then
amazon could say
look
we can't just take down the sites we
want
on aws we can't just refuse hosting to
those companies we would bring down the
whole internet if we did that
you know the whole internet is dependent
upon
this
decentralized infrastructure and of
course it's even possible that maybe
amazon web services wouldn't be behind
the whole infrastructure of the web
maybe other actors would be because of
different forms of decentralization so
through those mechanisms it is possible
to imagine
a kind of return to web 1.0
which was after all radically
decentralized
and what's fascinating about that
question and i you know i can't say that
i have a
strong intuition about what the right
answer to it is i mean predictively
is that it's really striking that web
1.0 was constantly being touted
we can remember this wasn't that long
ago as unique and original because it
was decentralized because you could do
whatever you wanted because anyone could
be anyone they wanted on the internet
because there were no rules
and then came web 2.0 and the
centralization of the platforms and a
lot of people made a lot more money in
that phase than they had done previously
because these centralized platforms were
able to provide services that it turned
out a lot of people wanted
you know the internet alone wasn't as
desirable to most people as interacting
via these platforms
and so the grand question on which this
turns is will enough people want to go
back
to the older system or will it be
possible through dissent
decentralization to give people the
kinds of things that they liked about
web 2.0
and so you know one of the places this
will play out is the metaverse this is a
grand and fascinating question will the
metaverse be this radically
decentralized thing a lot like web 1.0
was or will the metaverse come to be
dominated by a handful of central
platform actors who make money on it the
same way that web 2.0 operated
and you know there's a lot of talk some
of it utopian and idealistic
about how we're going to go back to a
world of radical decentralization and
maybe that's true and maybe in certain
respects that would be better probably
in certain respects it would be
but it's just an empirical question of
whether that decentralization can give
the kind of user experiences that enough
people actually
want
and i guess that that remains to be seen
and i don't i truly don't feel qualified
to have a view about whether that's
going to happen or not going to happen
well i love asking questions that force
people to speculate in areas where they
may or may not be qualified so let's
let's take a stab at that if you're open
to it
given just just given your
let's just call it legal fluency
constitutional fluency given your
awareness of various technologies and
trend lines
three years from now
if you had to place a bet
it doesn't have to be a large bet but if
you just had to
take a position in
what things might look like with respect
to free speech
what picture would you paint
in as much or as little detail as you
would like
i think that in three years
the largest players
in
[Music]
whatever platforms emerge metaverse or
other platforms
are going to be under a lot of pressure
to do the kind of content moderation and
regulation
of speech and conduct
that happened in web 2.0
and it's not just going to be speech
it's going to be stuff you do because if
the metaverse turns out to work really
well you're not just going to talk to
people there right in theory everything
you're doing on twitter is talking right
you're writing so you're speaking
but if you were in a fully immersive
experience you can also do stuff
you know you can play games you can
punch people virtually you can kiss them
virtually you know every other human
activity presumably you can engage in
virtually that's conduct it's not just
talking and so it's not even clear that
free speech would be the normal model to
apply to it i mean you can imagine
someone saying well that's all speech
because it's virtual and maybe someone
would think that that might turn out to
be right but it actually will i think
feel a lot more like
conduct i think already
some of the virtual platforms that
people use on the metaverse feel a lot
more like doing stuff than they do like
saying stuff so i think there'll be huge
pressure
for the companies in the first instance
to regulate the stuff that people can do
and say and if the companies don't do it
i think there's going to be a lot of
pressure on the government to do it and
so i think that especially if the
metaverse in three years is good enough
that people are spending a reasonable
amount of time doing stuff there it will
have to be subject to pretty substantial
internal private regulation and given
that
i think that
the kind of free speech from the
government that people want may continue
to exist but i don't think people are
going to be able to do whatever they
want in every
sub-part of the metaverse i think there
will be parts where it's do whatever you
want
you know
first-person shooter against you against
the world do whatever you want anybody
there'll be places to go and do that but
i think if you want the vast majority of
people to spend a lot of time in a space
it has to be pretty orderly
and it would be lovely if human beings
could order themselves spontaneously
but we don't have a lot of evidence that
they've ever managed to do that in the
past and the idea that they're gonna do
that the next three years in the
metaverse seems pretty implausible to me
yeah we have a very strong lord of the
flies history behind us i'm not sure
that uh human nature will turn on a dime
yeah and we'll turn into the
angels of our better nature immediately
uh one can hope you know
one can hope it'd be nice it'd be nice
any other i don't want to call them
predictions speculations for what we may
also see three years from now i mean it
seems to me if i had to bet i think
there's going to be a strong
centralized nature to what many would
hope would be decentralized metaverses
or a metaverse i simply think the
discovery process the interoperability
issues and so on may be so thorny also
the
frankly the
policing or moderating of conduct will
become such a priority for so many
players that
for those and other reasons many will
choose
centralized
companies or organizations rather than
decentralized
options that seems inevitable to me even
within
web 3 if you think about
a lot of what dictates behavior you find
centralized taste makers why because for
each individual to have the
responsibility to sort through the noise
to read the code to look at the smart
contracts to audit to do all these
things themselves is simply not feasible
unless you have infinite time on your
hands and the capabilities
so i do think
i'm fascinated by decentralization and
have invested very heavily in
web 3 and related technologies but
nonetheless i do think
people crave centralized sort of
authority and standards on some level at
least enough people do that will have
strong centralized players but
that's just my speculation
anything else you see
just over the next
say three years that you would
expect to see
yeah there is one other thing that i
think will be really fascinating and
important when we think about what the
next phase of web 3.0 will look like
we probably still don't fully understand
what the
ar vr interplay is going to be
right there's still people who say it's
all going to be vr it's mostly going to
be vr and people say no it's going to be
a mostly bar and i don't you know that's
a really fascinating and hard debate
my guess is it's going to be something
we haven't exactly figured out what it's
going to look like yet but let's assume
for a moment that a substantial part of
this is augmented reality so that it's
not just that we live all of our lives
in this to me dystopian world where we
spend eight or ten hours a day with a
headset over our eyes you know in a
darkened room we're still going to have
a lot of this technology but it's
probably going to go with us in some
mechanism when we go out into the world
so now what that does
is it makes it really hard
to work out
what it means to be regulated and what
it means to be free when you're
interacting
in real life with other people and
simultaneously interacting with those
same people or with other people
in some kind of virtual reality or
augmented reality
so the idea is you and i are having this
conversation right now
and we're connected by the internet and
we're connected by
video and we're connected by audio and
we're creating something in some sense
we're already doing an augmented reality
form of interaction but if you add in a
whole bunch of other layers and imagine
that we're walking down the street
having a conversation on multiple levels
simultaneously which is not so
impossible to imagine since after all
you see people all the time walking down
the street talking to each other both of
them on their phones which is just a
crude version of what presumably we'll
be doing in some in some future moment
so in that environment
the the really big challenge that i see
coming and i'm really only just starting
to get a sense of this now
and i haven't said this anywhere before
is that
the idea that you have one set of rights
and obligations
to the person you're talking to in real
life and another set of rules and
obligations to the person you're engaged
with in augmented reality at the same
moment
is gonna be it's not gonna work
it's not gonna work to have two
different regulatory regimes
involving the two of us at the same time
and if the government regulates what we
can do to each other in real life
and a private company regulates what we
can do to each other in this ar vr kind
of space simultaneously it's going to
get really messy and really confusing
you know what if you insult me or i
insult you
in some way that we would not be allowed
to do on the virtual engagement but that
we're perfectly permitted to do
interpersonally or flip it the other way
what if you punch me in augmented
reality or virtual reality which you
wouldn't be legally allowed to do
on the street because the cops would
arrest you
but i feel just as punched or maybe not
just as punched but very punched in some
in some dimension
if we really get so my takeaway here is
this if we really get some complex mixed
ar vr mix
it's not sustainable
to have two totally disparate regulatory
regimes
one coming from the government and one
coming from the private companies and so
this is a little bit intention with what
i said before what i was saying before
was that my base case is that we are
going to have mostly private regulation
in these virtual spaces
and continue to have mostly government
regulation in real life what i'm saying
now is
if we get this kind of really complexly
mixed ar vr thing that that equilibrium
will not be sustainable we'll have to
move towards some much more unified
integrated
kind of regulatory regime
and
that's going to be fascinating and it's
going to be really extremely extremely
complicated
my oh my the adventures ahead
makes me think of the apocryphal
chinese curse i've actually never heard
this in chinese so i i do doubt that it
exists but it makes for a good story
nonetheless which is may you live in
exciting times may you live in
interesting times one of the two
and we will certainly have exciting and
interesting
ahead
noah feldman at noah r feldman on
twitter
noah hyphenfeldman.com
have fun i really enjoyed this
conversation thank you for
taking the time is there anything else
that you would like to add
or ask of the audience point people to
before we
wrap up this first experiment in this
format
i love the conversation and i just want
to say to people out there who do have
real knowledge of or strong intuitions
about
the ar vr question and how we are going
to interface with each other and with
the rest of the world in the future
send me messages you know you can send
me an email on the website i would love
to talk about this because the deeper
that we understand what's going to
happen the more we can start thinking
through how to make it somewhat humane
when we finally get there i'm really
grateful to attend this fascinating
conversation so fun and for people
listening i want to just mention that
this is pretty close to the type of
conversation that you and i would have
offline if not very very close so
it's been really fun for me i've taken a
ton of notes
and
i i hope other people have as well
certainly we'll link to the names the
resources books everything that we've
mentioned
in the show notes at tim.log blog
podcast as per usual
and anything else that you would like to
add noah or do you feel complete
just that i love talking to you because
it makes me think of so many fascinating
and new things and your ideas are so
powerful it really it's super fun thank
you
oh thanks noah i really look forward to
hopefully doing more of these and i
would ask that anybody listening please
let us know what you think of this
format and you can certainly shoot me a
note at t ferris t-f-e-r-r-i-s-s
on twitter if you want bonus points it'd
be very helpful to also
tag
at team
tim ferriss i think it is uh it might be
team ferris but i think it's team tim
ferriss
but the easy way at t ferris and you
could just use
noah and that will help us
sort amongst the thousands or tens of
thousands of messages to find the the
signal in the noise and until next time
folks be a little kinder than necessary
read up on history it will help you with
the future and thanks for tuning in
you